make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so pinging back up with a fantastic
four again it's been a little while
since we covered Fantastic Four honestly
the first our guy I think we maybe did
half of it the first talk is everybody
coming back and that the part that we
didn't do was Ben Grimm basically
getting married to like Alicia masters
it was kind of a cool little thing but
in all reality it was only really
relevant if you had been a fan of the
Ben Grimm Alicia masters relationship
which I mean I guess was fine I mean it
didn't never really never really matter
to meet you much but the take away from
that little that little tidbit is that
at the end of that story
Galactus it basically arrived on earth
right and then like dr. Dooley made this
grandiose statement to the world of like
he was gonna be the one to save the
world and all all that kind of good
stuff
anyway that was it that's kind of where
that that one left off but in this one
it kind of actually like picks up with
the main event itself like with the
actual conflict itself now here's kind
of the funny thing here Galactus showing
up on earth is technically not supposed
to happen and the reason why is because
during the original Galactus trilogy in
the old Fantastic Four comics where I
the old Stanley Jack Kirby comics one of
the first major cosmic events or at
least cosmic cosmic themed stories to
pop up and Marvel and even in in
subsequent stories Galactus vowed never
to return to Earth and consume it unless
he was summoned by the Fantastic Four to
like actually arrive at the planet and
the reason why was because in that
original story Reed Richards had managed
to secure the ultimate nullifier right
which as we know or at least those of
you guys who have heard of discussions
on it now the ultimate nullifier is
basically a device that if it's pointed
at somebody and someone's capable of
using it to its full potential
you can like wipe out all existence
where I can like destroy an entire
universe on a baseline level it can
destroy a singular being now it is kind
of an interesting thing as well it is a
MacGuffin more or less it does create an
interesting scenario because the last
time that happened that like Galactus
died not necessarily at the hands of the
of the nullifier but the last time go
back to start we got a braixen now this
is one of those things where where dance
lots probably kind of picking and
choosing and it's being like there was
no Bob praxis in that's actually kind of
fine because a brat just was a cool
concept but he was never seen or heard
from again after the original story that
was told about him and never really even
referenced again so like that's that's
kind of that right I mean it's just sort
of out there is kind of a hand wavy
thing and that's basically the end of
that but seeing dr. doom face off
against Galactus it's actually kind of a
cool little moment because they've done
this more than once why they've done
this dance before and and this is
something that actually found kind of
interesting because Dan Slott makes no
reference to it and the original secret
Wars in 1984 dr. doom actually stole the
power
galactus and then eventually stole the
power of the Beyonder so it's not the
first time that dr. doom has done
something like this but it's also kind
of a cool little moment because this is
sort of a return to form for his
character right for those of you guys
who hadn't really followed dr. doom
really in in Marvel Comics in general of
course he was a foe of the Fantastic
Four and really even like the Avengers
and x-men in like the world for a long
long long time right like there was
never really an instance where he had
become a good guy he had had temporary
alliances with superheroes but he was
never really like a full-on good guy now
we go into like Secret Wars 2015 and
that's when like Doctor Doom basically
know when when the whole multiverse is
destroyed and Doctor Doom uses the power
of the beyonders to save what he can and
then holds it together the way he was
written was actually kind of a tormented
character right because it's like on one
hand I saved everything that I could but
on the other hand I acknowledge the fact
that I'm not Reed Richards and he
probably could have done it better and
that was the whole thing behind it right
like at the end of the the secret war
story it was finally the admission from
Doctor Doom that Reed Richards is better
than him now coming out of that dr. doom
got a new lease on life right like when
Reed Richards basically fixed everything
set it all back and then Marvel failed
to reboot like they should have we kind
of got a continuation of everything that
had happened before and dr. doom
basically went on so like try to become
a good guy and then became a full-on
good guy when like Tony Stark when iron
man died during Civil War to you and
then he became the new like iron doom
rightly you know the the I can't reject
what his name was a but but basically
like he was a new superhero and so like
would that being the case a new Iron Man
in him going around actually being you
know a hero even if he was only
teetering on antihero levels that was
essentially it but following like the
collapse of all that the end of all that
like his more or less defeat he ended up
retreating back to Liberia and something
basically happened that led him to be
killed going back to being essentially a
bad guy again
and it kind of sucks ah because he was
cool as a good guy but like you know
like I've always told you guys in Marvel
Comics everything always goes back to
the way it was before well it's the
nature of comics there's kind of a
status quo that's we've created things
change and then they go back which is
again why I never really understood you
know why people complain about things
changing because it always goes back
it's like complaining about the fact
that the Sun went down well yeah I mean
it'll come up the next morning so I mean
you know like it's it's it's kind of a
kind of an interesting interesting
scenario but again with doom facing off
against Galactus the reason why he's not
just immediately wiped out in phase out
of existence is because he's done this
dance before and so he kind of knows
what to expect
when someone like Galactus comes around
now of course what he's also joined with
is basically the herald of Doctor Doom a
chick named victorious now Victoria
showing up here is kind of interesting
we'll actually get an explanation here
in a little bit but she basically
defeats the Fantastic Four pretty
quickly and that's one of the things
that kind of bear in mind is depending
on who's riding the Fantastic Four
either they are like incredibly powerful
or they're relatively weak they're never
really in between there's never really
like a middle ground where like they're
pretty decent like they're there they're
pretty capable like that's never really
done it's always it's kind of like yeah
they're there and like they can be to
feed it pretty easily or it's like
Johnny Storm losing his mind going Nova
and like basically equating the power of
like a supernova and like destroying
something like it's usually something
along those lines like like what you saw
with with Hickman's Fantastic Four where
like Susan storm puts up a force field
that can like shield her from the power
of a celestial you know or at least a
bunch of a bunch of Celestials it was
temporary but it still worked and so
with that in mind of course Johnny Storm
is basically the only one who's really
able to kind of go toe-to-toe with
victorious and this one we kind of get
an explanation here that essentially
what had happened is that following the
the whole end of like dr. doom being
Iron Man and then retreating back to
Liberia that he just sort of existed
there but Latveria was in a state of not
really a coup d'etat so much as well I
guess it kind of was a coup d'etat it
was the forces that were loyal to
Latveria in dr. doom versus the forces
that were trying to conquer it all and
so what ended up happening is of course
like victorious came along and said hey
look you know her I guess you know her
name being Zora I came along and said
hey look you've got like dr. doom you
have to go back and you have to restore
order to Liberia which he did but
because of the fact that she was kind of
his champion right like she was the one
waving the banner and saying like we all
have to swear allegiance to dr. doom he
saw her is like his most loyal servant
like it was his most loyal citizen and
so because of that what ended up doing
was creating a device that allowed him
that's happened and harness the power
cosmic and then in turn applied it to
her now a lot of people will ask the
question if dr. doom had the ability to
harness and to endow someone with a
power cosmic why hasn't he done it for
himself and the reason why is because
the way to Doctor Doom is written it
would it would be like a coward's way
out dr. doom prefers to rely on his own
magic and his own powers which
admittedly are quite prodigious right
him he's an exceedingly powerful
sorcerer on par with Doctor Strange if
not a little more powerful depending on
what story you're reading with the power
cosmic it's more of like if I tap into
that power and I use it then what I'm
doing is I'm admitting my power is not
good enough and of course dr. doom being
as arrogant as he is would not want to
admit something like that and so again
like dr. doom showing up here facing off
against Galactus the idea behind here is
of course Galactus is just like wanting
to consume something but he's not
actually looking to consume the earth
what he has here is like a meet doom
destroys basically like these little
regulators for Galactus it kind of
maintained his hunger suddenly as is
kind of Galactus in his most unbridled
state when Galactus has no restraint and
that's what we end up finding out that
what he's locating at what he's looking
for is victorious and of course
intending to feed on and consume her
power cosmic and that's kind of the
crazy thing because when the Fantastic
Four start looking at this and doom
arrives on the scene they're like you
screwed up you miscalculated whatever's
going on here Galactus is like seeking
that power but it's not Galactus as he
normally functions as he normally is he
goes from world to world consuming the
life energies of that world but for
whatever reason he's going after her
with the power cosmic she possesses and
it's kind of a cool little moment
because when that happens what we get is
kind of this reasonable drop of
information will we end up learning here
is that in you over the time that Victor
Von Doom has existed in Liberia and
really you know even after his first
encounter with Galactus and the power he
possessed that out of the king of
Liberia he will go to whatever means are
necessary in order to preserve his
people but to also do what he thinks is
the right thing to do now just because
he thinks it's the right thing to do is
I mean it actually is but wasn't it up
happening here is what he needed or at
least what he wanted to do was use
Galactus as a power source now this is
not the first time someone's done this
right like we've seen that happen in
annihilation when the forces of a
nihilism the end the end the end the
annihilation wave sees Galactus and
turned him into an energy source we saw
it in Thanos imperative when like an
alternate reality version of Galactus
was basically turned into like a giant
engine capable of just like a minion and
basically kind of blasting a huge amount
of energy right like the Galactus engine
um with this scenario is really doomed
just intending to like use Galactus and
as ended all the power he possesses as
an endless source of energy that can
basically like power Latveria and
presumably the world but what he's been
doing is building like these massive
constructs that will siphon the the
power cosmic directly off Galactus and
that's why victorious was given her
powers because he knew it would draw
Galactus here and so what's essentially
happened here is Victor Von Doom
siphoned a portion of the power cosmic
off Galactus gave it to victorious and
then in turn galoshes is like where's my
portion of the power cosmic at who took
this from me and then tracked it down to
earth and that's why he's here it was
basically a giant piece of bait and so
with Galactus being here of course then
he begins a process of subduing him and
that's why I say if you were not really
Miller with like the various escapades
were Galactus and in Douma face off
against each other then it would kind of
seem like it came out of nowhere but
again referencing the old secret Wars
it's happened and so it's basically a
way to make it work and so with that
with that going on Galactus has actually
subdued pretty quickly by the forces of
Doctor Doom and is actually knocked into
a coma and when that happens like he's
just sort of there and just sort of
comatose but remember he's a giant
vector I guess a giant scythe and kind
of a gateway to the power cosmic right I
mean the nature the power cosmic is is
ambiguous it's like the Enigma force
it's just a source of power that exists
and like only Galactus can really tap
into it but landing on Liberia Mountain
what this means is that it allows like
all the forces of a Victor Von Doom to
begin like hooking up hoses and and
various siphoning devices and start
drawing this energy off of Galactus at
the same time that happens he also takes
a fantastic four prisoners and the idea
behind this is to basically just like
execute them publicly and just say like
this is the power Victor Von Doom has
and this is why you should all like
listen to me on this surface it kind of
seems like it's a pretty thin plot
pretty basic and almost a little
nonsensical it's actually not it's a
really great throwback to the old Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby stories because these
are the kind of stories that they made
and so of course with him basically
addressing the entirety of the of the
world you know what these little TV orb
things that he has and kind of calling
in today saying like I'm gonna execute
the Fantastic Four they're all gonna die
the world will no longer challenge the
power of Doctor Doom Oh what this does
is it allows the Fantastic Four to
finally make their move and the reason
why is because at the end of the day
when it comes to Victor Von Doom he
always loses for one of two reasons
either is straight up because of his
arrogance but he like underestimates a
foe he's facing or he overestimates his
power and so in this instance he
underestimates underestimates the
Fantastic Four and again like people
would look at that and they would say
but he's faced him like a million times
like wouldn't he stop under estimating
them and like estimate them accurately
like wouldn't he do that but that was
always the the kink in doctor dooms
armor is that he was so full of
arrogance and so full of hubris that he
always believed he had the upper hand
but Reed Richards has always usually
historically been shown to be smarter
than Victor Von Doom now again that
fluctuates the number one spot for the
smartest person in the Marvel Universe
usually fluctuates between Victor Von
Doom Reed Richards and Reed's daughter
Valeria Richards right is usually kind
of one of those three people who were
taking that spot at any particular point
in time but this kind of says hey look
the one thing that you didn't account
for is it like you haven't neutralized
our powers I mean you have to a degree
but you've got Susan storm get held
captive but all she needs to do to be
able to use
invisibility for example it's still like
have access to her mind the only way to
really defeat Susan storm agree to put
her in like a subdued state right like
put her in a catatonic state or
something like that where her mind is
shut down and so what she ends up doing
is basically using the one weakness
Victor Von Doom has and revealing like
his scarred face and his scarred body to
the entirety of the world now again
that's one of the reasons why I love
this because you would look at that and
you would say okay what does that have
to do with anything well remember the
one thing that Doctor Doom never wants
anyone to see is what he actually looks
like right like that's his shame his
shame is like his face being as scarred
as it is because he made it that way
he's almost like a fallen angel and so
with that happening that of course takes
away from him focusing on the scenario
he's taken away by by victorious and
then in turn reading company make their
escape and they intend to go after
Doctor Doom and basically face off
against him and things are done quite
readily he's defeated pretty fast I mean
like victorious iziz face off against by
the Fantastic Four they're defeated and
then of course like everything's pulled
away from from Galactus and then like
you know he begins to wake up and that's
when Doctor Doom makes his return and
they also are facing off against each
other but when we go lock his shows back
up again you know he's like he's like
I'm free now he strips power away from
out from Victorious who goes back to her
normal self he brings a power cosmic
totally unto himself and they creates a
kind of harness of sorts and then
basically this sort of takes off or at
least I seems to be in the case the
indication that he ends up leaving you
know as for dr. doom what is up
happening here is he's actually met by a
whole host of like demons right there's
a reason for this and then we haven't
really covered this little subsection of
the story but there's a reason for this
so while the Fantastic Four were
traveling to Latveria and they were
facing off against Doctor Doom um
Franklin and valaria were really one to
like follow along Franklin more than
anybody else that's kind of one of the
weird things that you see when it comes
to the writing of his character because
at the end of Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four run following like the
future Franklin coming to the present
day and then like defeating them at
Celestials and that kind of stuff that
Reed Richards went through and started
teaching his son how to use his powers
one of the things that kind of seems to
get lost out of that and even coming out
of like Secret Wars it's like yes
Franklin has his powers but Reed won't
let him do anything with him and that's
kind of one of the questions is how can
he possibly learn to use his powers
effectively in like a combat situation
if Reed never lets him use them and so
again that's kind of the weird scenario
that you went into with Franklin at the
moment but when he kind of gets
frustrated and when he leaves when he
takes off he suddenly comes across a
girl named Wendy now why did the clock
back to 1982 with really with his run on
the Fantastic Four and issued 200
and 39 I'm pretty sure it is you ended
up having this character really this
concept called windy and Friends that
was introduced by John Byrne and way is
played out was windy was a girl who
lived in Vincent Arizona and Vincent
Arizona was one of several communities
that was plagued by these demons that
were called friends and the reason why
they were called friends is because
windy referred to them as friends and
all we really had was the history she
gave but the way this would play out is
every 10,000 years
these demons more or less ease these
little these friends would basically
show up in in Vincent Arizona and the
surrounding communities and judge the
inhabitants you know as to their worth
of surviving by exposing them to like
their inner darkness where I like their
greatest fears and and so on and so
forth and some would go crazy and kill
others and then someone just flee the
area but those individuals who could who
could withstand that inner darkness were
judged as being worthy and those who
weren't either died or ran away but
windy was the person who actually
befriended the demons and just sort of
calling them her friends and so is it's
one of these things were like whenever
they would show up she was beyond
reproach not only that because they were
friends she could actually summon them
and so that's basically what happened
here right like Franklin Richards is a
friend of windy who basically ends up
travelling to Benson Arizona from a
dream sequence that he had and she
essentially invites him inside says hey
look we can watch this whole thing
unfold with the Fantastic Four and and
so on which allows Franklin to somehow
be a part of it and then of course that
leads to suits a wyatt Wingfoot tracking
him down and finally locating him and
saying hey we're taking you back home
and then Wendy freaks out and then just
like unleashes Oliver Oliver friends on
Wyatt Wingfoot and Franklin Richards
and then that goes into like Valeria
Richards creating a teleporter that
brings all the demons directly to dr.
doom and so that's really where they
come from that aspect is really more of
like the kitty side which I guess is
okay but we're talking about like a
teenage version of Franklin and valaria
right so I mean with valaria being
super-smart it is kind of weird to see
her written as like a child who just you
know I guess I really even Franklin
having a power he has AI being written
is like a child who's just sort of young
and goofy and and that kind of a thing
as opposed to like really like a
universal constant and somebody with
power on par with Galactus it is kind of
kind of weird to see it done that way
again it's really kind of taking the old
1960 style of story storytelling and
bring it into the modern day but again
it's kind of a cool little moment you
know kind of a cool little bit of
storytelling it's basically classic
fantastic for like 1960s Fantastic Four
now where this ends up going in is
anybody's guess because as we know with
Dan Slott when it comes down to like
writing serious stories
Dan Slott can do that like you can write
some pretty daggone serious stories so
I'm actually kind of excited to see
where this goes but with that being said
guys
to bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained and make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]
[Music]